well I have a very strong view that we
need to take a tough and robust approach
around the world to an appalling war
crime that's taken place in Syria but
I'm also a Democrat who believes in
consulting and listening to Parliament
and I think I've set out those steps in
a very deliberate and careful way but we
have to listen to Parliament Parliament
spoke and Parliament I think made a very
clear view which it doesn't want a
British involvement in military action
so we will proceed on that basis but I
think that's right to have a strong view
to put a strong principled case and then
to listen to Parliament I'm determined
as a prime minister to do things in a
different way to the way they've been
done in the past to make sure Parliament
is properly consulted and to listen to
the result you will respect Parliament
which still stands that you actually
think the decision yesterday was wrong
don't you well I think it's important we
have a robust response to the use of
chemical weapons and there are a series
of things that we will continue to do
we'll continue to take a case the United
Nations will continue to work in all the
organizations were members of whether
the EU or NATO or the g8 or the g20 to
condemn what's happened in Syria it's
important we uphold the international
taboo on the use of chemical weapons but
one thing that was proposed the
potential but only after another vote
involvement of British military in any
action that won't be happening and that
won't be happening because the British
Parliament reflecting I think the great
skepticism of the British people about
any involvement in the Middle East
because of all the difficulties and I
understand that that part of it won't be
going ahead have you spoken to President
Obama have you apologized to I haven't
spoken to him since the debate and the
vote but I'd expect to speak to him over
the next day or so I don't think it's a
question of having to apologise I think
it's a question of saying to a fellow
Democrat you didn't a fellow as well but
that's that I think that's the point
look I was faced with three things I
wanted to do right and do in the right
way first of all to condemn absolutely
and respond properly to an appalling war
crime that took place in Syria secondly
to work with our strongest and most
important ally
the united states who've made a request
for british help and thirdly to act as a
Democrat to act a different way to
previous Prime Minister's and properly
consult Parliament now I wanted to do
all of those three things that obviously
politics is difficult it wouldn't of
course that involve going to Parliament
making an argument in a strong and
principled way but then listening to
Parliament I think the American public
the American people and President Obama
will understand that Paddy Ashdown says
he's depressed and ashamed Britain is
now just going to shrug when children
are burnt your own Chancellor said this
morning that he hopes that Britain
doesn't now just turn its back on the
world's wrongs I mean this is a very
significant moment is that when a Prime
Minister is over all by Parliament on an
issue such as this I I don't agree with
Paddy Ashdown I mean this is still the
same British Parliament that voted to
take strong and principled action to
stop Colonel Gaddafi murdering and
massacring his own people in Benghazi
this is a British government and a
British Parliament that's leading the
way on how we tackle poverty in the
world it's a government and a parliament
that is deeply engaged in the world with
the fourth largest military in the world
and one of the best diplomatic networks
any country has in the world we have
great strengths as a country we should
continue to use those but on this
specific issue because of the huge
concerns about this appalling Syrian
conflict and people worrying about how
we might get sucked into it on this
specific issue that trumped as it were
the sense of outrage about the chemical
weapons now I understand that I get that
we will not be taking part in military
action but it doesn't change every
American does whatever happens in Syria
there's further use of chemical weapons
it's ruled out British Parliament has
spoken very very clearly about its views
about military involvement that doesn't
stop us condemning chemical weapons it
doesn't stop us condemning the Assad
regime it doesn't stop us working with
allies to bring them maximum pressure on
this regime and the appalling things
that it's doing but on the specific
issue of British British military action
I think that was the message of the
debate and of the votes last night votes
in which it was interesting that you
know both party leaders the Prime
Minister couldn't get his motion the
Labour motion
I regret that we were dividing the house
rather than trying to bring the House of
Commons together I worked hard to do
that
neither motion passed two final
questions relating to that did the
Labour leader Ed Miliband behave
dishonorably in your view well it's a
matter for him to defend the way he
behaved and his conduct look my only
regret is that it wasn't possible to
build a consensus of all parties I
worked hard to try to do that by making
clear how we'd go to the UN listen to
the inspectors Hall the second vote but
in the end opposition leaders have to
make choices just as prime ministers
make choices I made my choice about how
to handle this issue doing the right
thing in the right way learning the
lessons of the past but I regret it
wasn't possible to have that consensus
in the house but in the end that's the
secondary issue the real issues the
House of Commons spoke and the
government will listen finally two
ministers missed the vote the whips
obviously didn't do a very good job how
are you going to reboot your government
now well I think the whips did do a good
job there was a huge amount of contact
with colleagues a lot of discussions
many of which I held myself and I made a
sincere and I believe powerful argument
but people have equally sincere and
powerful views in a different way that's
what Parliament's for that's what
democracies for we vote we decide and
then we act accordingly as for the two
ministers who missed the vote this was a
technical issue they were there they'd
made it for the first vote they were in
a room in the House of Commons where
they didn't hear the Division Bell they
missed the vote they've apologized
profoundly have accepted that apology
but it wouldn't have changed the result